what does your shirt say it says oh no
my queen
oh which actually reminds me of a funny
thing that happened earlier today
I think I'm done with duck chests
but I'll leave everyone with one funny
story okay so earlier today I stopped by
the St Louis chess club
and there's like a small kind of
Skittles free play area
[Music]
um where they have the the broadcast of
U.S chance
and there were a few people that wanted
to play me so
one of the people that I played
he said that like he hasn't really
studied or anything he's like very new
to thinking and he didn't even know who
I was
um so I agreed to play a game
and I played E4
and keep in mind like he was just pure
beginner
so he played Pawn F6
and in this position I play Queen H5
and he found the only move G6
I played Bishop E2 and I said oh no my
queen
and he didn't even Flinch like or
hesitate he just took it
and then Bishop H5
and uh
yeah I had to tell him that it was
checkmate
but uh yeah no mercy
even for someone very new to the game
that was nice I was wearing those shirts
if you want a shirt like this you can
use the merge command
shop.imrusen.com
you can also go to onommyqueen.com and
it should redirect you
I didn't say call an ambulance that
would have been too much